boy and girl superpowers whether the
creatures mean any harm and how they
affect animals adjust some of the
crucial details revealed and the
original bird box book that don't make
it into the movie yippee chimera levers
I'm John and today I'm explaining seven
major plot points at the Netflix film
bird box change from Josh malla Mann's
novel obviously film and book spoilers
ahead if you've seen the various
daredevil bird box memes you might have
been struck by how the Marvel heroes
superhuman radar sense would have helped
him in the post-apocalyptic world of
bird box but the bird box novel actually
explored a similar idea in detail with
boy and girl becoming extra sensitive to
sounds and super skilled at echolocation
in the book Mallory
ruthlessly raised the two children to
never open their eyes and when they were
babies she'd stand over the pair and
when they woke up she'd smack them with
a fly swatter if they open their eyes or
reward them with food if they kept their
eyes closed in the movie we often see
boy and girl indoors with their eyes
open although there is a very short
scene where we see Mallory teaching the
kids to use stones to figure out how
close an object is this gentleman when
you're louder you're in an open space do
you hear that but if they're softer
something is very close but in the books
her training is much more extensive in
the book version of the river trip
Mallory uses a children's heightened
abilities to help her navigate by
identifying sounds and nearby objects in
fact boys hearing and echolocation
skills are so sharp that he's able to
detect when one of the creatures is
nearby and when it's moved on and both
he and girl can also sense subtle
changes in Mallory's emotional state
just from her breathing by the way in
the book Mallory is so fearful of the
children accidentally looking at a
creature that there's a chapter where
she almost pours paint thinner into
their eyes to blind them so they can't
ever be tempted to see now I mentioned
how in the book Mallory and the children
encounter one of the creatures while on
the river it's a terrifying moment
because the three of them have just been
hit by a flock of suicidal Birds some
boy has just heard that something is
right there with them the thing moves
around the boat and then it starts to
slowly pull Mallory's blindfold off her
face but she puts her hand on the
blindfold and tells the creature no this
is mine the creature seems to like
the blindfold and then moves away until
boy tells her it's behind them now this
up-close encounter which doesn't make it
into the movie raises a question of
whether the creatures deliberately mean
any harm there's no doubt in the book or
the film that gazing upon them is lethal
to most people but the novel spends more
time exploring ideas about what they
really are in the book after the
creature lets go of Mallory's blindfold
she remembers something that Tom said
which is that maybe they mean us no harm
maybe they're surprised by what they do
to us it's an overlap their world and
ours just an accident what Tom seems to
be suggesting is that the creatures are
probably from another world maybe even
another dimension and they accidentally
arrived due to some kind of cross
dimensional rupture also book Malory
after refers to or thinks of the
creatures at infinity because as Tom
also said whatever they are our minds
can't understand them they're like
infinity it seems something too complex
for us to comprehend in the movie we get
various hints as to what the filmmakers
maybe thought the creatures represented
and they seemed to suggest a more evil
perhaps demonic like force Charlie
listed a series of malevolent spirits
and entities during his speech about
what he called the endgame for Humanity
and in the final scenes of the movie the
monster seemed to be actively hunting
Mallory and the children in the forest
which is quite different to how it left
her alone in the book when she ordered
it to stop Douglas is a new character
created for the movie in John Malkovich
plays the abrasive role really well some
of Douglass's traits are inspired from
the book character dawn who like Douglas
is generally not keen on letting new
people into the house and opposes
letting in both Olympia and Gary however
in the books dawn later becomes friends
with Gary who tells Dawn's stories about
people who've opened up the blinds in
their homes and suffer no harm the pair
end up discussing ideas such as the
creature can't cause harm to someone who
is prepared to see them book Mallory is
very suspicious of Gary and snoops
around his belongings discovering a
notebook inside his briefcase
the notebook like Gary's drawings in the
movie reveals his State of Mind with
Mallory finding sentences written left
to right right to left top to bottom and
even in spirals she also discovers some
ideas in the notebook that portray what
Gary is really up to and indicate he's
likely already had
with the creatures for example he writes
to know the ceiling of man's mind is to
know the full power of these creatures
but how to prove it to them how to make
them believe I will remove the drapes
and unlock the doors Garry ends up
getting kicked out of the house however
we later discover that Don secretly let
him stay hidden away in the cellar
by the time Mallory in Olympia give
birth don is thoroughly brainwashed by
Gary and Don opens up the blinds in the
house which results from the death of
everyone except Mallory unlike the film
Tom also dies at this point in the novel
by contrast in the movie Douglas is
skeptical of Gary throughout and even
attempts to shoot him to protect
everyone in the house
however he ends up dying at Gary's hands
overall the subplot with Gary runs for
much longer in the book and his
reappearance when Malory and Olympia
give birth is a huge surprise as it
assumed he'd left the house a while ago
something the book provides more detail
on is whether the creatures can also
affect animals and there are some grisly
passages which prove that yes they can
for example there's an especially
horrific scene where Malory and a dog
she's with encounter a creature and the
poor dog kills itself another
particularly bloody scene in the book
occurs on the river trip when a flock of
birds see one of the creatures the birds
go insane attack each other and kill
themselves which sends down a wave of
dead bloodied birds onto the boat
spattering all over Malory and the
children given the movie toned down some
of the more horrific elements from the
novel I can see why these animal
suicides also once included another
detail the movie changes from the
original book is Mallory's decision
about who should look so they can safely
navigate the river the film spends a
good bit of time building up to
Mallory's dilemma of choosing which
child will take on the potentially
suicidal mission of looking when they
reach the rapids it's a heartbreaking
moment with some great acting by the
young actress who plays girl
okay though of course Malory decides
against the plan and tries to figure out
a way for everyone to survive in the
book however they don't have to travel
through any river rapids instead
Mallory's predicament is that she needs
to look when the river splits into four
channels if she has to take the second
from the right in order to make it to
the sanctuary book Mallory actually
plans to look very quickly herself when
this moment comes but it's just as much
of a dangerous moment as what happens in
the film because it comes just as their
boat bumps into the creature I mentioned
earlier although her time in the film is
short
Mallory's sister Jessica played by Sarah
Paulson certainly makes an impact given
the rapid horrifying nature of her death
after seeing one of the creatures
Jessica's early demise quickly isolates
Mallory and demonstrates just how high
the stakes are that works for the movie
however in the book Mallory's sister
whose name is Shannon survives a lot
longer as the apocalypse doesn't happen
so suddenly
in fact Mallory nurse's to hunker down
at their home for several months until
one day the corner of a blanket covering
a window comes loose and Shannon sees
one of the creatures the loss of her
sister makes Mallory feel vulnerable so
she drives to a home that's acting as a
safe house where people are trying to
survive together the movie
understandably wants to set the tone
much more quickly so it brings on the
apocalypse in a very short timeframe and
on top of that rather than a place
organized to take people in for shelter
Greg's house is simply a normal home
that a few survivors are lucky enough to
find more or less randomly first box
ends on a fairly optimistic note where
Mallory boy and girl arrived at the
school for the blind and discovered that
dr. lapin has also made it there in the
book
although Mallory and the children do
reach the safety of the school the river
journey has been even more harrowing
than in the movie with Mallory getting
slashed in the shoulder by a wolf and
also passing out at one point and the
books final chapter is also much darker
and bittersweet because what Mallory
discovers at the school is that some of
the residents have gouged out their own
eyes so they can't be tempted by the
monsters in the novel Rick tells her
that many years earlier the school
security was much weaker and a creature
managed to break into the building
resulting in many deaths the community
then decided to blind themselves to
avoid any further risk from the
creatures although since then they've
improved their security and now new
arrivals no longer
that by the way the original screenplay
for the movie also had a difference but
similarly horrific alternate ending to
the one we saw in the final film and you
can tap here for all the details on that
plus other deleted scenes from the movie
so what did you think of third box and
if you've read the book how do you feel
about the way it was adapted let me know
in the comments below if you're new here
and enjoyed this then do subscribe and
hit the bell to get all my new videos
coming up next week I'll have videos on
glass and in the meantime you can
tapleft for seven monstrous things you
missed in bird box or tap write for the
movies alternate ending and deleted
scenes thanks for watching and see you
next time you pick a movie lovers